there's nothing like the good old days
that moment our lives where everything
was just right you know what i'm talking
about
maybe it was in high school when you
were captain of the football team
or it could have been while your kids
were younger and you were just starting
your family
life was good
for our economy though the good old days
were just a few years ago when trump was
still president your dollar went a whole
lot further under trump you could fill
up your gas tank for less than two bucks
a gallon
and the stock market was doing so well
we all looked like geniuses
the 401ks
they're up 90 95
i always tell the story people come up
to me they say i want to thank you my
wife thinks i'm a total loser sir
she thinks i am the worst person with
money with financial
she thinks i'm just horrible in the last
three years
i'm up 94 sir she thinks
i'm a total genius when it comes to
father
well in biden's america
we're now all fools no longer geniuses
because i hate to say it the good old
days are over
our economy has officially reached bear
market territory today the s p fell 20
percent that's officially now
collapsing
now on top that the nasdaq is off about
20 this year and the dow is about 5 000
points down
since january that's the longest losing
streak since the height of the great
depression and there's no sign of this
is going to slow down either wall street
says this recession is here and things
are about to get a lot worse
i can't sugarcoat it for you guys our
savings could be about to get wiped out
i mean 401ks are about to get smashed
right now and we're going to lose and
we're going to lose a lot gas prices are
hitting record highs inflations are
hitting highs companies are now
freezing hiring that means layoffs are
coming
but this doesn't sound important to the
white house
what does nothing has changed on how we
see the start market uh we do not that's
not something that we keep an eye on
every day so i don't i'm not going to
comment about that from here
scranton joe
may not care about layoffs or your 401k
is getting annihilated
maybe he'll realize it when all of his
wall street backers stop bailing him out
and donating to him
but as of now remember he's no mind
reader
so now americans have to worry about
this looming recession during this
ridiculous summer we're about to face
and on top of worrying about the war on
the inside of our country our southern
border is about to see a biblical flood
of migrants coming through when the hot
weather hits this is migration season
we're heading right into it right now
we're gearing up to see millions and i
mean millions of illegals pouring across
our southern border
title 42
thank gosh
is no longer
going to be preserved
what we have right now a judge
thank gosh
just preserved it and so we still have
that right now as a weapon but that's
just a band-aid
that really isn't going to stop what's
really going on
and right now joe biden is out of the
country
he's in
south korea
right now he's not making america great
again he's trying to make
south korea great again he's touring a
chip factory in south korea mixing up
the names of the prime minister over
there
he's trying to pivot to asia we need him
to pivot here to the united states of
america
and we need it done quickly
i don't know what else to tell you about
joe biden but the man is shot he's no
longer capable of governing this country
and the american people are paying a
very very severe price for it
i don't know what else to tell you to do
it's going to be up to the communities
the mayors the governors
we're going to have to do that ourselves
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else